school is right around the corner just a
few days away it's approaching fast it
can be hard though to keep your child
motivated engaged in learning with so
many things competing for their
attention mary jane belliesa is live now
at sunset montessori community on sunset
and pecos with how experts say you can
help your child prepare for the school
year there's so much that can take their
attention right mary jane
oh sherry absolutely and like you said
i'm here at sunset montessori a local
school in the southeast valley i'm
joined brian early with gail swift she
is a colby youth advocate and gail thank
you so much for waking up with us now
tell us what is a colby youth advocate
and how do you help parents and children
a colby youth advocate gives children
students the opportunity to know how
they solve problems their way
and when they know how they solve
problems their way through a tool that i
use they have motivation
to learn and to keep learning throughout
the year and as we know that's really
important as kids go back to school they
had summer off they weren't thinking
about school maybe in the slightest
until you know right around next week
and how are you helping parents and kids
during that time
when students know and can identify
their way of solving problems it's not
the drudgery of having johnny or susie
be forced into homework or projects or
wanting to go to school because when we
know how they work the motivation is
there and they actually desire to learn
and keep that going and it's through a
test that takes about 30 minutes
that i do with the student and that's
really interesting to learn because i
think that's a big misconception right
that's something that you can't change
this is innate this is the student is
born with this way of taking action it
is not your personality you cannot
change it so i have a phrase that i use
going with the grain instead of against
the grain for your students best efforts
and that's also important to remember
that everyone has different learning
styles so it's really how you work with
your child to really help them get
motivated to get back into school and
keep them motivated all year long
absolutely yes this keeps them motivated
perfect well thank you so much gail
we're here in the sunset montessori
community of course this is on the
valley on eastern and pecos and i do
have victoria montessori who is the
founder and a teacher here at the school
thank you so much for joining us brian
early you know school is right around
the corner how do you help your students
stay motivated for the beginning of the
school year and through the end
well here in montessori it's very fun
and the kids have the freedom to learn
and that makes it very exciting and very
inviting and that's why they are
what this is what motivates them to come
and to learn something different every
day
so this is the way that we try to
motivate them all throughout the school
year
and you're also a mom you have a
seven-year-old daughter and you know how
do you help her get ready for school get
excited and really help her stay
motivated
well i try to include her and everything
that that has to do with school so
together we shop for the
supply list
getting the new backpacks
also
practicing for school lunches and you
know making me help
just make some eggs or whatever she
wants for lunch it's really the little
things to help you know get your kids
engaged and help them get into that
school routine very important especially
with school around the corner it's going
to be hard to turn on that light switch
right to get ready victoria thank you so
much for joining us reporting live mary
jane ballaza live local now